where do you want to start here Charles
hey Dan are you doing I really don't
know where to start I'll know whether we
should start with Germany whether we
should go to the naval academy or
whether we should talk some of the
in-depth stuff I'll let you decide the
team whose draft you love I like what
Baltimore did and being able to
stockpile and turned into players that I
think are going to help them I think the
fourth rounds going to get a ton of
attention and rightly so because they
have all those pic stock piled in the
fourth round a that five picks there I
think each one of those guys can give
them value but there a god there's a
guide that when the fifth round Matt
judaa and outside linebacker/defensive
it from grand valley state I think will
eventually be a really nice player in
the draft for them inhale a team with
camel area to give them some pass rush
and they're going to need to start
filling that in trail Suggs would be
back we had to Achilles you know Elvis
Dumervil they don't want playing full
time he's more effective when he's a
designated pass rusher but I've got to
find some people to fill in i think they
made a nice move towards doing that what
did you think of the dallas cowboys
dream i liked it because i've been a
proponent physique Elliott for a long
time I didn't do it in my last mock
draft but I've talked about having that
runner and I know people keep to about
the position being devalued and I just
don't believe that I think it's a
position that's evolved but you've got a
guy who can be a high-volume runner but
then you also have a guy who can protect
her passer which is why Tony Romo will
want them on the field for three downs
and can catch the ball the backfield
that's what you're looking for and it's
not as simple as okay now you've got the
right runner you plug in you immediately
12 and 4 again if they wear with DeMarco
Murray they start to keep Romo upright
they still have to be able to do other
things step to get better on defect but
I like that but I was puzzled I have to
admit as much as I love the Jaylon Smith
story which is phenomenal him getting
drafted I still kept saying okay where
are the defensive ends that you don't
have you've got two guys who are
suspended for the first four games of
the year and I'm just not one of those
guys damn that believe
well okay so they're suspended for four
games when they come back we'll be okay
they're suspended for a reason you don't
know how they're going to come back you
don't know that whether going to make it
all the way through your year if they're
dependable who did they draft Charles
tap or defensive end from Oklahoma was a
good player but I don't think he's a
terrific force in patent rushing the
passer and I didn't see anyone else so I
still have that same question who's
going to be the defensive end pass
rusher that you need in this lake and
that's what Dallas still has to start to
solve more surprising that the big 10
quarterbacks were devalued or that you
have the Tampa Bay Buccaneers using a
second-round pick on a place kicker I
think it was more much more that the big
10 quarterbacks were devalued because
the kicker had been rumored for a long
time and you actually had cover and I'm
using air quotes for that word in taking
a kicker now because we talked about the
new p80 rule and we saw where it drops
what about five percentage points from
the previous year's to last year in
moving it to the 15-yard line so now
people are saying okay you better be
dependable at the kicker position even
for extra points because that can cost
you games so that made that more of a
premium and aguayo was clearly the best
one coming out this year so I kind of
expected that to happen even though I'm
still struggling with second round but I
get it quarterbacks well we all thought
cook would come off the board as the
fourth quarter back and when he didn't
it went to okay why didn't he you go
back to what you'd heard before and all
that he did to try and dispel the
leadership not being named captain how
people like them or didn't like him so
the morning of day three then I talked
to three different personnel guys three
different teams independently and all of
them told me that they had lousy
interactions with it so that's what it
led me back to okay this is why lousy
Oakland take the SFA I mean lousy was
one word and I'm using it as a consensus
for the others I won't use what would
one team said so that's what they that's
what they were talking about this is a
big deal for him now to get this
opportunity in Oakland and it really
kind of mirrors Kirk Cousins coming out
same school
being drafted for cousins in the exact
same draft is Robert Griffin the third
in Washington everybody say why would
you why there well if he's better than
your backups you might want to go get
him and Cook has that opportunity now
it's up to him if indeed that's truly
what the issue has been formed clear
that up and go play because I think that
he is better talent wise than the
backups that are on the roster right now
for Oakland even though he'll be behind
Derek Carr Charles Davis NFL network
analyst you cover college football a lot
in the Laremy Tunsil situation is this
one of those watershed moments where
kids with social mean I say that it
still comes up social media is going to
play a role in the draft probably from
here on out but how do you think this
impacts next year's draft of what they
have on their social media if it's
Facebook or Instagram or any of this
nonsense I hope it impacts it dan I
really do but we have people who are
talking until they're blue in the face
to these kids already I mean let's just
be frank about the whole thing we can go
to any one of these big-time schools
offseason and preseason practices and I
will guarantee you that for the last two
to three years minimum coaches have
brought in people to talk to them about
social media and what happens when you
leave things on your phone and who you
can trust and not trust and no matter
how close you think you are with your
friends you shouldn't do things that you
can put on on a video or have them walk
out with pictures I mean when go on and
on ad nauseam they've already been doing
that yeah when will people actually get
the message and not do it because you
and I both know every year we come up
with stories now this one is the biggest
one because it was the draft this was a
kid who may have been the number one
player in the draft right on down the
line but you and your dream team there
could guarantee I can guarantee right
now you pulled up and go you know kids
social media bad move and the things
that just jump off the screen at you
from high schools and i'll just start
with that on up i know people who are
making a good living that being social
media consultants going from school to
school high schools colleges junior high
the schools and kids about what to do
not to do on social media come with you
it's going to play and they have an
impact but the idea that you know the
message isn't out there in the words not
out there for kids it's out there it's
just when are they going to choose to
get it done and get it done properly my
kids high school basketball coach this
year told them today's your last and
social media until our season is over
anyone who's caught on he told him what
the rules were and they were going to be
severe reps in the beginning he got them
all off of it in high school I kind of
see it in college I think it's a little
more problematic because they're older
and they're gonna have to deal the real
world at some point anyway but all you
can do is educate and hope that they
listen and do it right it's fun watch
with you guys with the NFL Draft Charles
always great catch up with you thanks
for joining us thanks for having me Dan
you take care of yourself Charles Davis
NFL network analyst the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience